[Music]
surprise Emma Roberts and Garrett
Hedlund are starting a new chapter I'll
actually tell there is a secret the 29
year old actress is pregnant with the
couple's first child according to
multiple reports I don't really have a
lot to spill I'm curious to see what
that's gonna be like and then Garrett
first sparked dating rumors in March
2018 when they were spotted together in
LA after the scream queen star ended her
engagement to actor Evan Peters I'm
speaker had to put you back together
okay all the best pieces the former
co-stars first started dating in 2012
and were on-again off-again until their
split last year as for headland he
previously dated Kirsten Dunst from 2011
until 2016 here's what he told ET last
March at the triple frontier premiere in
New York shortly before he and Roberts
were linked do you have a date here
tonight alright cuz you look good you
can't be rolling along can't bring a
date on a work trip I think for me it's
like surrounding myself with good
friends and my family and it seems like
that's exactly what Emma is doing with
her Tron Legacy beau spending good time
with friends and I know just doing stuff
that makes you happy
the actress definitely seemed happy when
she posted this bathing suit photo on me
24 had to do it you got to do it
it's the last photo the actors shared of
herself prior to reports of her baby
news here's Emma eating fried food while
lounging in the grass living her best
life oh my goodness by a pool is how I
hope that's my happy place no signs of a
baby bump then but we can't wait to get
our first glimpse there's some other
things I can't spoil and one can only
hope Emma and Garrett's baby inherit the
Robert's family smile we have a lot of
teeth congratulations to the parents to
be
[Music]